good afternoon my name is Tom Graham and
I'm a senior lecturer been doing at the
Macmillan Center used to be here at the
Jackson Institute but this is a
wonderful environment and I want to
welcome you to our next session in a
speaker series on Russian politics one
of the big questions we always ask is
where is Russia headed particularly
finding out what happens post Putin and
perhaps even more than that when we
finally get the post Putin and we have a
wonderful speaker here to help us think
through the Russian politics today
particularly take a look at this from
the people who are in the opposition to
Putin in the real opposition not the
opposition that in the Communist Party
or the Liberal Democrats what we tend to
call either in Russian or in in the West
they some systemic opposition and we
couldn't ask for a better person to
address this issue for us we need both
cook is a little fellow at Yale he is a
leader of Russia's future party he has
been deeply engaged in Russian
opposition politics for many years
associated most clearly with Alexei
Navalny also a former world fellow here
at Yale 2010 if I if I remember
correctly help run his campaign for
mayor of Moscow and most important his
campaign for president of Russia into
18 he's also had experience at the local
level having served in the City Duma and
he kept it in bordered by several years
back and added to all of this he's also
an IT professional so he understands
modern communications he's written a
book on cloud democracy which is going
to help us think how you redefine
reshape democracy and elections in this
modern communications Europe he has his
own company's internet protection
detection society that is looking at the
digital aspects of a politics in the
21st century so the way we're going to
run this session today is Leonie is
going to give us about 40 45 minutes
upfront his view of Russia that we
welcome all of you to participate what I
think will be a very lively a question
and answer period so the Ennead it's all
overdue
[Music]
[Music]
sorry now now it's better
sorry actually the part I like most of
this kind of talks are questions and
answers to see what's interesting for
audience and and to go where it goes but
I can't switch immediately to that
because I see people very different ages
backgrounds academic non-academic zone
so I probably have to spend like several
some time to put everyone on the same
page and then I'll try to give my
perception of what's going on in Russia
currently and what's our strategy I mean
our positions strategy regarding this
moment and then finally we all get
questions and answers so once again I am
chief of staff for Alexei Navalny and
the deaf guy who is always making used
by being detained and arrested and
released and arrested again but apart
from this he is running a largest NGO in
Russia called the anti-corruption
foundation we
as active since eight years and there's
all those famous anti corruption
investigations brink corruption to the
agenda and that's very important because
corruption is how Russia is run
organized and governed now these days
Alexei Navalny Sante corruption
investigation investigations made him
the leader of the Russian opposition he
verified this status participating in
the Moscow mayoral election of 2013 when
he finished surprisingly and the second
place was almost 30 percent of poplar
wood and nearly forcing a runoff is
incumbent mayor Sergey Serbian after
that he was never any more admitted to
the ballot in any election probably
because well putting considered it too
dangerous
it doesn't matter still he is building a
large political organization which is
able now to impose even more pressure on
the Kremlin on the regime and doing it
in very various way through YouTube
videos through three trolleys through
participation or by cut campaign but by
cut campaigns of the elections and in
many other ways proving itself to be the
only independent source of political
activity in the whole country they only
independent from from Kremlin and that's
why it's so important I'm a proud member
of this movement which you could call
novel only team or anti-corruption
foundation or the Russian future
priority it doesn't matter so when we
have to participate in election maybe we
are the Russia's future part even when
we support Alex see in some
anti-corruption from the campaign we we
we say it's a project of a
anti-corruption foundation it's not that
important it's just well then a
volunteer movement the opposition
movement
I'm a proud member of it since well 2011
working closely with Alexei as his chief
of staff and occasionally also as his
campaign manager my education and
background is in mathematics and
computer science so quite surprisingly
for a political manager but that's
because that's mostly because we
actually have to use internet technology
and all all kinds of new technology in
our political operations because we have
no other way in hazzard choice
so since at least 10 years we are cut
off any mainstream media no access to
television newspapers radio networks
whatever and internet in the last couple
of years mostly YouTube remains the most
important media most important means of
communication with the Russian waters
with our supporters so a lot of
technology has involved in our political
operation in December 2016 Alexei
Navalny announced he would run in the
upcoming presidential election which
took place in March 2018 he spent a year
building a network of regional campaign
offices regional campaign head
headquarters we finally had 87 of them
and 65 of Russia's 85 regions really all
over the country all over it's 11 time
zones this local election campaign
offices organized the activities of
several hundreds thousands of volunteers
and supporters doing like door-to-door
campaign some some call it a very
American style political campaign
distributing some campaign literature
spreading the word online offline by any
means and the aim of this well political
operations aim of this movement was to
get Alex
registered on the ballot that was a
technical task we had to collect 300,000
signatures to get him registered and
those is a political task because I mean
the decision F
Alexei would I would not be admitted to
run in the presidential election was of
course primarily a political decision he
was not admitted the star that the
boycott campaign declaring the this
March 2018 election a completely fake
election which it was in fact and the
most important thing we did and we are
continuing continue doing as we kept
this network that we built during 2017
alive so of course we had to scale down
a little bit because we rely completely
on crowdfunding and micro donations
there is no other source of funding of
our political operations but what our
supporters donate to us so of course
after the campaign they the presidential
campaign came to the end we had to scale
it down still we kept 45 of the original
offices we have the presence the
political presence in any Russian city
with a population of 500,000 and in some
smaller cities as well which is very
important because those 45 regional
offices remained the points of
crystallization of any kind of political
activity would be some ecological
protest or anti-corruption investigation
or they participate in the nationwide
anti retirement age reform rallies or
whatever but these 45 regional offices
is in you assets that we have built we
have created from from scratch during
all the 2017 campaign our regional
offices run
under enormous pressure it's very common
for a regional coordinator to get
detained arrested some occasionally
beaten up to face different problems
he's your relatives being fired from
their jobs all kinds of administrative
pressure is applied still it's up and
running it's very important that we keep
this network in place and my daily
operations still even by here at Yale
are includes coordinating the efforts of
these regional offices of this network
managing the project the local projects
they run and also involving them in
Russia wide scale projects so that's
very vast and that's how our movement
looks like now in very brief terms of
course and that's the movement movement
I represent here why we are doing that
why we are not waiting for the next
election cycle why we are keeping mmm
this network despite all the pressure
Kremlin puts against it why we are well
putting our people and the risk one
could ask why don't we spend the
donations in some other way on some
other political operation not in the
regional Network maybe the answer is
that we believe this pressure they
create daily weekly monthly as itself
very important it's now a very important
factor of Russian politics and here I
want to describe where in my opinion
well Russian politics stands now what's
a critical conflict within Russian
politics what's what's happening why at
the end of the day why the Putin's
approval rating is going down
dramatically
20 or 30
even more even according to the
state-sponsored and state-owned polling
agencies this is something which never
happened before but now in the last six
months he went down from well seventy
five to maybe 45 points being under
fifty is actually something something he
never experienced before so what's going
to come why and why is it so important
to keep and develop our regional
organization our regional political
organization under such circumstances
the model I keep in mind is the
following so Russia now it's a very
typical mafia state so it's
unfortunately I hate to say it but it's
nothing special this planet has seen
similar regimes everywhere in Africa in
Latin America in Asia even in Europe
it's just a mafia state and well we have
the Godfather and he has his lieutenants
and those lieutenants are immersed in in
permanent conflict so imagine one top
member of a Russian political elite
maybe a governor of some large and rich
and some some region rich natural
resources and imagine a natural member
of top Russian political elite who would
be like really puddings right hate
right-hand lieutenant like Igor Sechin
who is in charge of all oil experts or
imagine someone who is in charge of gas
exports aluminum exports of drug imports
or whatever what they doing there my
face usually they always are in conflict
so consider a oil field and that rich
region who would take the rent from this
oil field who would be the first on
stealing this is the proceeds the
original governor is a head of the state
oil company they both want to
participate in this create a conflict
and the only tools to resolve this
conflict the only mechanism of arbitrage
is for them boys to appear in kremlin in
putin's office on the carpet pretty much
like this and well to argue in front of
him and to take his decision as final
and granted and that's the only way
there are no other instruments natural
tools of of resolving the conflicts of
arbitrage it's all very personal it's
very important how long the waiting line
outside puddings office is and who takes
which place in this in that in that lane
so how often could section or Rotenberg
orchid Arif access Putin personally how
many minutes or hours of putting
personal time this or that lieutenant
have that defines a lot it's a very
personal istic very personal is regime
very authoritarian and based of course
on corruption so Russia is still a very
rich country the oil prices are high
once again and they are all dividing
this despite dividing this assets
somehow another important thing about
Russia in 2018 is that no institution
has any own legitimacy
so they trust the support of the the
popular support for the Parliament or
for the regional authorities or for the
church the army the government s for the
institution's it's very low it's
somewhere around like 10 or 15 points
for for any of those institutions people
generally think
that any government officials any member
of Parliament's any governor's and
ministers are thugs and thieves and
their right of course they they indeed
are the only exclusion being putting
himself so before March 2018
he was definitely by a very wide margin
the most popular the most supported
politician in the country and that's why
that's what ever all the system relied
on the governor or the Minister doesn't
have his or her own legitimacy all the
legitimacy is inherited from from Putin
we have to as the citizens of this
region they have to OB to obey to our
governor not because we elected him VP
we didn't not because we trust him we
don't but because he is appointed by
Putin and putting his good as it's our
we trust him and we trust his decisions
and his appointments and so on and
that's how it operated very successfully
in the last 15 years and pudding was
very successful in building the balance
of power between all his lieutenants
making closes judgments like you get the
30% of the bill you get the 70% of the
deal and all state in depth room on that
carpet and that was enough looks like
it's not anymore enough the system is
losing this stability why it's happening
I think well my answer we could argue
I'm not sure this is actually the
correct answer but that's were where I
am now
my answer is that before 2018 before the
re-election it was the optimal
collective strategy for the system to
work to function that way to increase
Putin's personal approval rating and
legitimacy it was their collective
strategy
see maybe this governor or this head of
oil company would not be happy with this
very particular decision dividing the
proceeds and the assets indeed in this
ratio but as a whole as a political
light they still would be happy because
well at the end of the day every one of
them would get the piece of the global
pie and the pie was huge I mean really
huge they only buy official statistics
they export fifty billion dollars yearly
like in assets outside the country and
the oil and gas proceeds there are over
three trillion dollars in the last 15
years and only a very small part of this
landed on the level of population the
the largest part of this pie exists now
in form of Jack's private jets palaces
and some other luxury items so it was
important for the system for any member
of the elite to invest in putin's rating
including his approval
like if something bad was happening
you'd never see mr. president personally
at the place of a fire or a flute or a
plane crash but we would see him in
winter olympics it's integrating and you
I didn't know breach or Stadium or
something like this they all would keep
this idea that everyone in the
government
everyone in power is bad but mr.
president it's are is good the boyars a
breath this is very old Russian idea and
suddenly it was working good enough and
in the 21st century as well now
sure the reelection the elite at least
that's how I feel it is now starting to
change this balance this collective
strategy because it doesn't fit anymore
the average age of the world member of
political elite is not changing like the
average age of the governor of or a
member of government is about 4550 years
and it was the same 15 and 20 years ago
they start to think about the post Putin
Russia about the exit strategy about how
to keep their assets their position
their power after Putin and of course
it's very successful reelection of
putting him on in March 2018 only
ignited all those way of seeing all
those controversies because ah now the
next election would be well in 2024 only
wouldn't will be well 72 years old which
wishes a lot he already didn't once run
for the third term so in 28 he decided
not to run himself obeying does this
only part of the Constitution at least
the succession issue is on the table
once again so it wasn't all six years
between 2012 and 2018 it wasn't it was
absolutely clear for everyone in the
political elite that well what will
happen in 2018 everybody knew that now
it's not that clear anymore and they
serialize slowly but they realize they
have to
invent some new strategy sir I mean 15
years ago
a typical elite member could think that
well Putin will be literally forever
they will well reach there and you know
biological and pretty much well at the
same pace at the same time now it's not
any more truant if I am a governor like
45 years old I have to think about my
post Putin existence so I have to start
investing in my own approval rating I
have to start investing in developing
some other mechanisms some other tools
for for other arbitrage which would
create not mmm oral agreements but
something more solid some rights some
asset rights which would not disappear
when Putin goes away I can't prove it's
what what's happening right now but I
see a lot of small examples that the
processes and our going that way in
Russia the first one i-i'll give three
of them very briefly but those who
follow Russian politics will probably
understand me why these examples are so
important the first one is this a
general kind of case so the public
conflict between the head of the
state-owned state-owned oil company and
the government member secretary of
economics this conflict resulted and mr.
OWL kyuf being indicted for 10 8 10 10
years in prison for alleged bribe for
for and attempt to get a bribe for from
mr. session something which couldn't
happen in putin's russia ten or even
five years ago a conflict which would
not which none of its parties would try
to resolve in a public court damaging
the general image of the power like Wow
a very very top member of the government
is trying to bribe another very very top
member of the government it of course
doesn't contribute a lot to the well to
the authority and the approval of the
power itself for some reason they be
choose the other array of resolution of
their conflicts not relying on Putin's
arbitrage anymore but well relying on
the public court system the second of
course is a second time example as what
happens what happens is the scruple case
it is a poisoning in the Breeden pudding
went to television himself and himself
he said all those stupid things that
everyone was making jokes and still is
making jerks off like this were just
tourists we found those peoples and not
poisoners they're not gr agents they
were just occasionally visiting
Salisbury and enjoying the famous spear
of the Salisbury Cathedral yes still
funny but what made him make fun of
himself
this never happened before you can
compare this vis-a-vis bowing mh17 case
just four years ago we didn't ever say
like any students any stupid sinks he
never saved any provable lies on mh17 he
just said well let's wait it's all
unclear he had all the propaganda
machine to blame this on Ukraine to
develop all kind of conspiracy theories
but he never expressed himself and the
way that everyone could just make made
fun of him the same happened to the
retirement age reform which which is the
most important thing happening in the
internal
now the reform is very unpopular but
it's not the first very unpopular reform
and ration model in history twelve years
ago we had this occult monetization
reform which was also very unpopular and
actually really made the life of
millions of Russians worse and it's very
interesting to compare Putin's behavior
now and 12 years ago because 12 years
ago he just didn't say anything public
on that unpopular reform why why should
he he had the government government
would would take the blow and he would
always like blame everything on the
government's they're responsible for
economies they are doing probably some
good things and some bad things that
thing is probably not so good but he was
never held personally responsible for
that quite rigorously and the retirement
age reform he spoke up
he even recorded a special well video on
on television he took all the
responsibility himself which actually
resulted in a dramatic drop in his
approval rating
why should he looks like the system is
not anymore that interested in pumping
in in increasing Putin's personal
approval ratings the system is looking
for another ways to prove it
legitimacy to another for another ways
to build its operations that's a
historical and very dramatic change
happening in Russia now so the political
elite starts to consider putting to be a
lame-duck the political elite does not
anymore follow the strategy of
increasing his personal legit legitimacy
in the proble rating by all means and
the political elite is trying to find
another way to resolve its conflicts -
well - to survive or to
to persist to keep its assets and all
those yaks and palaces and Sun so what
what should be the strategy of Russian
opposition under these circumstances the
truth is that there is still not that
much wicked well we have to admit we
have to admit that there is still quite
a high probability that the system will
be able to survive until Putin's death
that's definitely his personal strategy
he wants to stay in Kremlin before he
dies he doesn't want to resolve the
succession issue he doesn't have anyone
he could really rely on around him and
we've seen a lot of examples and in this
world and post-soviet countries when
even those guys who looked like very
reliable for the leaders for auto-return
leaders who appointed them didn't want
to follow their faith something what
happened in Turkmenistan something good
now is happening him whose biggest and
many other countries as well he just
want to stay there till he dies and
frankly we have to face it
with the oil prices has 85 dollars per
barrel and if nothing like really very
dramatic happens like and it's not here
in the clear war which is still probable
Putin will be able to stay there like
for another 20 years
that's a probable scenario unfortunate
very dramatic for Russia very bad for
Russia but but but probable see if he
managed to stabilize his alights if his
elites he will be doing well the second
scenario if some is some like Black Swan
type event like something really
dramatic happens people go out on the
streets he get just how's that and some
dramatic change happen
it's also probably we've seen in like
the Arab Spring started in Tunisia in
2011 by some random event which ignited
the crowds and led to a revolution to
welter to the most dramatic revolution
in and 21st century and the short
scenario that we have to consider it's
big internal struggle the consensus of
the political elite is not anymore that
they need Putin as a supreme arbiter
supreme referee for their conflicts and
they start to reinvent this the system
and while the system collapses or not we
didn't know all of the the good news is
that in my opinion whatever of three
scenarios happens there is not much
chance for those now in power in Russia
to stay in power as everything has now
built on very personal relations and
very personal ties and very personal
agreements between Putin and this and
that of his lieutenants it's not really
inheritable after he is gone no matter
what of three scenarios they'll really
start to fight with viz each other
trying to achieve a new balance and this
will be exactly the time when we will
just have to go out on the streets and
demand for a new system for the regime
change for fair election and our chances
will be good because near none of his
lieutenants none of the current small
leaders will be able to regain even like
10% of the power of Putin has now what
we don't know is we don't know which of
this three scenarios we
actually happen and we also have to
admit that we have no tools to influence
the probability of the first and the
second scenario we can't call a Black
Swan we can't make the old guy die but
we have we can increase the probability
of the search scenario we can increase
the probability of the internal struggle
by increasing the costs by affecting the
cost-benefit ratio by making it more and
more expensive in the long term
perspective for the political elite to
keep the system as it is to do this we
just need to impose more and more
pressure as much as we can and that's
good news because it's what we are doing
our basic strategy actually I mean
remains the same during all eight years
70 years I've worked closely with Alex
in avonlea being part of his movement is
to work hard to grow as a political
organization
to invest everything in the growth and
to use any anything what happens in the
country as a tool to create stress to
create more pressure on the government
on the regime on Kremlin so so before
the most Camaro campaign we had maybe
eight or ten staff and had very little
experience of organizing political
campaigns after the Mescalero campaign
we had 30 people after the presidential
campaign we now have 45 regional offices
and over a hundred people our support
base has grown from
dozen thousand of subscribers five years
ago to several millions now on Alex's
YouTube channel on our mailing list and
so and so these two parts of the
strategy are actually very current when
you do something when you try to do new
projects when you launch new projects
when you address the issues that happen
in the country when you organize rallies
against the retirement age reform or
when you try to participate in any kind
of elections oh do something on regional
level it increases the amount of
supporters people sees that you well
that you are actors that you are
fighting against the regime and people
join you and when people join you when
your support base grows it increases
your ability to impose pressure on the
Kremlin so the honest answer is that we
have to be patient and keep going keep
doing what we are doing we don't know
the Ursuline change happens we don't
know when the regime change happens we
know that we can do a lot to increase
the probability that it happens sooner
than later and we have to be best
prepared we have to be the largest and
best organized political power in the
country when it happens that's our
strategy that's actually very simple not
rocket science but so far looks like it
works so now the internal turbulence the
struggle within the political elite is
as high as it never been well in the
last 15 years and hopefully will not
have to wait too long I hope so thank
you
yeah great 40 minutes so we have 40 more
minutes do you want to stand up thank
you very much Leonie for that wonderful
comprehensive overview I want to ask you
one question and then we'll turn to
everyone else but I know there'll be a
lot of questions could you give us a
sense of the demographics of your
movement who are your supporters you
know those you know hundred people were
working actively before you but broader
than that so the target organ audience
was in Russia the people were going to
go out in the streets you're going to
provide the type of visual evidence of
your political strain yeah thank you so
much
it's it's a very important question also
because it's an important talking point
of the propaganda that like novel
movement is just for high school
teenagers this is not true they do
actually a lot of research and polling
on our own supporters base the just
today launched another questionnaire II
asking our supporters to to fill some
form to reply about their demographics
son the average age of a supporter
registered in our database is if I'm not
mistaken
24 years they yank but not too young the
visible part of our supporters those
volunteers very actively involved in
like in door-to-door style events and so
on is indeed very young well that's I
think it's true for every country it's
easier for a person to get involved in
like door-to-door political activity
when the person doesn't have have like
three kids and a mortgage so high school
students or undergraduate students are
of course very important for this type
of events but that's not the correct
image of our whole
what is very important is those
volunteers active in the streets are our
only media so that's very sturdy
we don't have an access to television
radio on since the volunteers are our
media we had measured this during the
Moscow 2013 election I refer to this
experience because it was the last
election we actually participated and
that despite the fact that the most of
the volunteers were like very young the
largest amount of words alexei as a
mayoral as the candidate to mayor has
got a monk like women 50-plus probably
among their mothers is this because
those young volunteers were our media to
build outreach to other audience that
are not that active online that we can't
reach through our like YouTube channel
and and so and so so this is a question
of demographics of our support basis is
very important it's very interesting for
us as well but it's it's very diverse
another fun fact and very important it's
what we discovered during the old 2017
campaign that the presumption that all
the political activity is concentrated
in Moscow and Petersburg while maybe
nervous abuse can Ekaterinburg isn't any
more true the largest rallies so when
when the Owlman came to a city we beat
around surity rallies sort of like
public events with his with him speaking
from from the podium in front of a huge
crowd the largest two events of that
style in terms of percentage of
population of the city attendance their
movements can Smolensk so to City you
never think of like protest cities or
centers of political protest in Russia
still this ver is the largest I'm gonna
use my bracket Matthew one more client
sure
assume what happens what you want to
happen happens
and Putin's gone Navalny is now leader
of the country what are the first three
steps he takes
oh it's a very good question because
it's very easy to answer we had exactly
this on the presidential program when we
published it release of political
prisoners the court reform because it's
it's essential you can't have free press
fair elections nothing without
independent courts and now I mean you
can't debate an election you can't
debate like anything in court because
the judicial branch is not functioning
as an independent branch so it was a
second serve political prisoners court
reform and fighting interruption
which is a very which is a number of
very concrete steps we have to take like
well I don't want to go very much into
detail but because we started as an
anti-corruption movement we really have
like very detailed low proposals on what
we have to change in Russia to to start
fighting the corruption
I mean bet me hues are good news the
corruption is so deeply rooted in the
Russian society and system that a there
are so many low-hanging fruits you
really could like now apply 20% of a
force to to kill 80% of the problems
because two of those okay but you're
gonna start with rule of law rule of law
exactly okay questions if you raise your
hand please at dinner wait for the mic
because we're recording right right we
have certify yourself and ask the
questions uh the young lady right here
yeah so who's helping does a mic up
there we office
thank you for being with us
my question is other than the communal
pressure what other factors are
contributing to the political elite
moving away from working for expanding
or increasing put in support base but
rather turning to themselves so sorry I
have to ask you to ask this question
once again
so what is what what prevents is a
political elite from explaining their
own support base
you know like other than the communal
pressure what makes the political elite
turn away from working from Putin's
political base for from like Putin but
rather than invest in themselves
why did wire the so basically why are
the political elite now turning away
turning their backs to put in but not
what why didn't they do it before but
what changed now yeah sure once again
firstly because now the succession
question is once again on the plate so
no one had a doubt that what what is the
scenario for 2018 election now it's a
lot of uncertainty uncertainty about
2024 I mean it's even not clear if Putin
will actually try to run or to change
the Constitution and transform Russia
and to like invent some other position
for himself or try to place a Medvedev
scenario runs again it's all very
unclear and also this will try to
explain this age difference is growing
between and between putting the average
elite member and it makes the average
elite member to think about the the post
Putin figured future
hi my name is Elena I thank you so much
for being here thank you for your brave
presentation I'm from Ukraine and
related to that question to what extent
do you think that Maidan revolution
change or really find Russian opposition
do you think that it was a source of
inspiration or perhaps something that
could be extrapolated as a model in
Russia as was the conversation in 2014
and then related to that is what's the
big idea in Russia if in Ukraine for
Maidan protesters it was EU integration
rule of law does the Russian opposition
have a similar big idea start design the
second part of your question of course
there's a big ADH rule of law and
inequality I mean Russia is vv run the
whole 2017 campaign on inequality and
injustice and Russia is officially the
country this is the high highest gini
coefficient in the world the relation
between the income of 10% richest and
poorest so the level of injustice and
inequality is a as they come together is
enormous and this in people's perception
is also something like very unfair and I
mean the Moscow dealership of Bentley is
the best selling in the world and by
official statistics I think 23 million
people live below poverty line this and
that's what someone like really sees
every day that the only rating where
Russia really managed to maintain stable
growth during all put in 18 years is a
rating of the number of billionaires and
we actually now the second in the world
after the US and the number of
billionaires see this was always our
main talking point and is our main idea
and of course yeah we have to fight
corruption to fight inequality
and it all comes together and it's very
easy to explain - well a regular water
in Smolensk what's wrong because I mean
the salary of this water would be around
three hundred dollars or maybe even 250
and the only career paths the only dream
would be to move to Moscow and it's of
course very disappointing now the events
in Ukraine the Maidan revolution in 2014
made a very complex impact on the fate
of Russia and Russia's Russian
opposition who didn't used this to annex
Crimea which suddenly happened to be
very successful and I'm sorry to be bit
cynical but happened to be a very
successful move for him which boosted
his approval rating enormously he kind
of felt this as a political animal he
felt this would be a large success and
and it was a large success
well then ii put in invested a lot in
creating turbulence in ukraine invading
invading not only Crimea but the vast
region investing in any kind of
turbulence do you have this as a as a
counterexample like you all know this
buzzword which taka teachers to be like
a kook Rana you don't want and to be
like in the Ukraine which is the main
talking point of all the Kremlin
propaganda over the last four years so
of course I mean they put enormous
efforts and doing the life in the
Ukraine as complicated and as bad as
possible to use this as an example for
their propaganda before that quite
successfully so now after the 2018
election after the pension age reform
not anymore so looks like people start
to understand that you cannot put Crimea
on the piece of bread
and put it in the fridge still I think
that the fact that the Ukrainian
revolution was not that successful and
didn't lead to like real change and
increase in the people's life level and
so on well it's still important as and
essential is as a part of Russian
opposition of course we I SH
Ukraine all the possible success - for
for Putin not to be able to use this
trump anymore right follow up on that
have you had contacts with Ukrainians
who led the Maidan and and thought about
tactics in common what works what
doesn't work no but I mean vvv observed
it of course we we know a lot of what
happened what was beautiful was bad but
they don't have any their context it's a
question down here
and then down here thank you for your
talk
my name is Dominic you you call
yourselves the real or possession but
recently in Russia the Aronofsky party
started winning these elections in in
kind of regional areas like Khabarovsk
and I mean yeah how do you interpret
that and how does Navami can he channel
an opposition that may take a
nationalists kind of direction or do you
you know I just be interesting what your
views of that recently well yeah look
the relative success of RIA Novosti and
the Communist Party in the recent
regional elections only proofs for the
point that well that's why you don't let
us participate in those elections
even those clones those technical
candidates who actually did everything
they could did not to win still one runs
the election in fact in a recent year
Russia has seen five russia has gone
five times through the second front of a
regional election like when the
incumbent didn't achieve 50% and the
first round and there was a runoff and
in every of these cases the the
incumbent lost and in the second round
and lost dramatically like the 45 to 25
and the first round converted to shorty
to 17 in the second because when people
see is that there is there is an
opportunity to defeat United Russia to
defeat the ruling party people turn out
to the polls and what for whoever
doesn't matter just for the fact that
this guy doesn't belong to the ruling
party so this only proves the size of
the protest potential and why we have to
and access to ballots participation in
the elections and why we keep demanding
it it doesn't prove any like nationalist
stunts or whatever I mean no one what's
four million of skis candidates because
you're in a ski is a nationalist or or
something
he's nothing he has no Fuson on politics
on political issues the only reason
people vote for his candidates is they
don't belong to the Putin's party it's a
clear anti put in what and that's why
it's important hi my name is Yvonne so I
have a question about like you
absolutely right that when the official
Italian that it can be much worse if you
choose somebody else right so and people
who lived in Yeltsin time can compare
how they lived before and how they live
now like I left Russia when it was still
Yeltsin in power and then I coming back
like every seven years and every time I
come back I see life is better and
better and last time I was in August
it's even better than it was seven years
ago
and people different like young
generation smiling talking about
everything all generation yes some
suffer but some still have small
businesses and it's working yes they
complain for corruption they complain
that there are some issues but it's
basically common complaints which can be
everywhere my question is about
different thing when I hear what a
position saying most of them saying
exactly the same how bad is in this time
in Russia how bad
regime how bad these how bad but none of
them saying what is our way to make it
better just step by step what we can do
differently what you can do differently
from Communist Party who still has like
thirteen percent of waters and I check
what divinely published in his
presidential election half of this is
make pension for everybody make medical
care for everybody like American Sanders
and it's not different from what
communist is saying because they also
appeal into the same group who grows in
time of Soviet Union when everything was
free and yes that's what I'm asking you
how you can make yourself different from
communists for this part of people who
will what and how you can solve these
problems if there is no money industry
in some cases is collapsed and you just
come back office what became a president
what you can do like not just declare we
have a new use judges we have what new
laws but how that will work because
people still there and you have no team
like is anybody experience in government
or if anybody can do something for
industry and planet because thank you
for the brief summary of the main
talking points of the Kremlin
I mean it's so the life is good as it
never had been especially in Moscow
people are smiling in the streets you
don't want to back to the 90s you don't
have a don't have have a team and you're
saying just very common things about
like making the salaries and pensions
higher and that's all
Sandra style [ __ ] so that's that's
that's important that's a talking point
we face every city we go every crowd we
talk to that's that's absolutely okay I
can give a very short answer well I have
to address you to the presidential
program which is very detailed and
addresses all these issues and still
available on the website the most
important thing is first there is money
in the country the country is enormous
reach and the corruption the level of
corruption is what doesn't allow for
people to well live decent life the one
number to give the average kickback for
a contract for say road construction in
a road construction procurement was
around 5% in 2000 and is around 70% 7-0
percent now in 2018 so the corruption
bird burden on the economy has grown
like 15 halt in this last 20 years and
if we just follow the very basic steps
to reintroduce rule of law like
democracy in demand press fair elections
and independent courts will be able to
well divided largest part of this
corruption and this will immediately mmm
make country and its people much richer
now I realized it sounds like once again
not not rocket science it sounds like
very simple but it it hasn't be
different because it is actually very
simple so I mean the the challenges that
Russia faces now of re relaunching the
economy and treating civilian rule of
law are not different from the
challenges many of the countries faced
after an authoritarian regime came to an
end and a lot of countries from I don't
know Spain or Indonesia or Chile resolve
this issues very successfully and over a
short period of time
just basically I'm following the
question because it's a protest movement
it's an opposition but my question is
you have a lot of local officers local
bases I you mentioned that you basically
try to attract different movements
environmental movements all kind of
movements how about some again I don't
know anything about his party
orientation but there are some figures
who are doing very positive drop on the
ground for example if Gainey royzman
she's very popular and he was elected
and basically I guess he was very
positive image so my question is it's
all Moscow Petersburg some other cities
for rallies but how about kind of
attracting someone who really has some
experience in real kind of the next step
which comes after well yeah thank you
see first of all it is true that Russia
and Russia is a huge country which
produces which still produces an
enormous amount of talent and also of
political talent of managerial talent
and we tried to work with this talent
and to embrace all of the independent
politicians in the regions to include
them into our movement royzman is a
brilliant example we were not very close
like 10 years ago now he's a close the
closest ally and we do a lot of things
together with him Maloof is another
example
Yashin of course and and some other so
it's well it's actually so not true to
say that we don't have a team because
the fact are the facts are actually
quite the contrary we we have a
brilliant team which consists of many
politicians and managers and business
people and also of course our own staff
that we with the incubate and
I mean every of our regional heads of
regional offices is a person who went
through enormous pressure enormous
problems and have proven themselves to
be a very well effective manager
efficient manager they build political
organization and in their city rank
almost no resource and while still
organizing to a lot of political
pressure and so on so the fact is that
every of our regional office curtain
makers would be much better governor of
the regions and also because it's hard
to be worse
so thanks Pete Peter Rutland the the
apartheid regime in South Africa
collapsed after part of the business
they lead and even part of the security
police started negotiating with the
opposition so how are you that there are
business groups in Russia and even state
officials in Russia who are willing to
come over to your side yeah Peter thank
you so much it's it's an important
question so far we haven't seen any
direct movement from from in Cairo from
the existing parts of political elite or
business elite towards us well the risk
to be poisoned is probably a bit too
high but I mean we feel that there is a
lot of you know whisper there and
probably we don't have to wait too long
before they try to reach out but what's
important they measure a lot of protest
mood among the police for instance so to
give an example so we published a large
investigation about corruption in the
national court and then the launched a
poll
among the police officers in a social
network where they have a group for like
police officers active asking like whom
to trust more the leadership of the
National Guard or Navalny investigation
about their corruption well 30 percent
we were supporting the leadership of the
National Guard 70 percent were
supporting us that's good but two months
later when we launched like a second
investigation there was this famous
story was saw what of the head of
national worth asking only for dwell and
well but long story short after we
publish the second part of investigation
and gave more even evidence there was
another poll in the same group which
resulted in a taint 10 to 90 in our
favor so over a relatively short period
of time we kind of shifted and the end
the group has like hundred seventy
thousand members most of them police
officers so we we gained 20 points among
this audience which is well which is
quite impressive I would say yes
Andres Development Center thanks a lot
for your talk I have two questions
one is about coalition building so no
transition happens without effective
coalition and you started talking about
that so you have some powerful allies
etc but you have any particular strategy
like what are the business groups that
he would like to target or what are the
political groups interest groups or
broad so in abroad in broad societal
sense what are the groups that you would
like to approach first to make the
formidable coalition against the regime
yeah so I have a very quick answer they
will be we will be able to build a very
efficient coalition when there is time
to build a coalition and this time is
when it goes to a favored election and
very
a reason to build a collision there is
not need to like unite for the for the
sake of unification
there is a reason to unite to achieve
some goal so recall the 2013 most Camaro
election I was head of the compare the
campaign office I had like 200 people in
my can benefit from the moderate
nationalist to LGBTQ activists who well
under other circumstances would probably
like try to beat each other but they had
a common goal a very clear run like
together let's say elected all together
as as many votes as possible and this
very naturally contributed to building
of a coalition and this will happen the
next time so we have here Dalia
because a libertarian no no no and she
was on 2013 Moscow campaign stuff and
well apparently we are quite far away
ideologically from the Libertarian Party
but there is no doubt then I mean during
the presidential campaign a lot of
members of the Libertarian Party joined
our regional offices and worked in our
stuff and if there will be like a next
election where we'll be admitted to
suppose where there will be a chance of
course we will work together so there is
no need to build the collision
intentional Israel it will be formed
when there is enough reason for say yes
thank you and maybe one short question
if not only one what would his cabinet
look like do you have an idea what's the
what's the they wanted to publish
actually the potential cabinet if he
will if he would be admitted and to run
in 2018 well we had to now I would
prefer not to do this well also also
because it could be harmful to some of
these people but the main principle
would be of course meritocracy and
competition
so we would run open contests for any
position as we beat it on our campaign
trail like we so we had 300 stuff during
the campaign like three four people in
every of 80 regional offices and all
these positions were filled through an
open competition we had like six
thousand CVS and people competed to get
those positions the principal Thank You
mr. Volkov for sharing your thoughts you
said in response to another question
that support for parties like Juden
laughs keas and the Communist Party is
actually evidence for support of
opposition parties like your own and if
only Novotny was allowed to compete
people who vote for him and that nobody
is actually voting for clowns like Jaden
offski well the thing is that
politicians described as clowns have
been winning elections and they've been
winning elections in countries that
haven't been fed media diets of extreme
nationalism for the last 10 or 20 years
so my question for you is why do you
think that progressive liberal parties
like your own if suddenly we had free
and fair elections in Russia would win
as against parties like Sudan off skis
which have an appealing narrative and
have had media exposure yeah thank you
it's it's a valid question the answer is
is it because we are better in
campaigning sir before I mean before the
mask on Moscow mayoral election the
approval rating we were measuring she
was about three pints but what what
what's what's important is the campaign
the outreach the ability like to work
hard and to spread your message to get
to the people and here we are just
stronger as a political organization
because well jury Nastya has no like
brown stuff no ability to reach out to
people so of course we will have to
fight but we are completely ready to use
a fight and I mean
campaign is is how wars are won that's
that's an argument for a rich rich
Kremlin used a lot awesome why should we
admit now only to the presidential
election if here is somewhere around two
points in the polls
and it was true the other part of the
truth what well they didn't know and
they didn't want to check where we
should go through a campaign through a
massive outreach campaign within if if
if admitted and I think we will be able
to beat very no scans the Communists by
a wide margin I mean that's still my
feeling I dream of having a chance to
prove it I'll try to keep my answers
short as possible via we're gonna work
this side and then we're gonna end with
you yeah we have to get ready in seven
minutes icing because the next but
middle on the event okay okay thank you
very much my name is Roman Baraka I am a
mathematics teacher here in the yes and
a former head of the unit for European
Union and Russia cross-border
collaboration back in Moscow in the
Federal Minister of Economy I want to
concentrate actually on one point how
would you ensure if any of those three
things scenarios takes place how do you
ensure that actually fail action will be
held in Russia well there is no warranty
of course that's something we will have
to demand and something we'll have to
fight for but zero I get well there is a
fair chance that we'll be able to
achieve it because well we have a
trained army of election observers we
have a lot of experience we know how the
elections wreaked and what's wrong with
the current elections so it's I'm not
holding it for granted but it's a very
feasible
okay thanks very much for a talk and I'm
more interesting the foreign policy bit
of Nibbana government if he were elected
how are you going to deal with countries
like China these days the war in Syria
how you're going to deal with it or are
you going to end it directly how are you
going to deal with America and also what
kind of countries will be your allies
yeah Vincennes thank you but I'm afraid
I'll not be able to cover this and the
remaining several minutes it's a sudden
switch from from internal politics the
two different politics what we have
heard among our supporters during all
the year and they have campaigned as the
key to Russian foreign policy is and
it's internal policy that's it DeMint of
our supporters that we have to stop
investing in Syria and Ukraine in
Central African Republic whatever
whatever but we have to start investing
in Lebanon homes hospitals in varnish
and rot quality in in Vladivostok that's
a very important popular demands our
voters our supporters don't want Russia
to like mimics the superpower and to
place the scenarios of the Cold War to
be that active on the international
scene as put in tries to be and actually
I think I believe it's it's a good
strategy do you return Crimea to Ukraine
the failure answer as they it's not
possible and the Crimea will remain a
major problem of international politics
for at least next 50 years
hello my name is Jessica Ramsey and I'm
a senior at Glastonbury high school and
I'm studying Russian politics and
demographics so my question is what does
Navalny suggest to do about the readily
declining population and in particular
low birth rates in Russia hmm well the
truth is it's not rapidly declining and
the birth birth rates are not very low
z.i they are comparable with
average European Suzy demographic
situation in Hungary or in Finland or in
many countries are much worse than in
Russia but well the the basic answer is
that if we see in economic growth we
will see also the demographic situation
as better so now if you consider well a
young couple in a small regional city to
get a baby as a adventure which requires
a lot of bravery the situation has to
have to change sure you wait for the the
microphone please
it should be switched on yeah you
mentioned judicial reform is the number
two point yes the current one is pretty
much spoiled how where are you gonna
find so many qualified lawyers
prosecutors and so on and the second
part is how you can make sure that like
the Stalin style prosecution doesn't
repeat itself in Russia well it's it
doesn't repeat if you don't repeat it
the first question is more important
well I would like Michael to be here we
have a fantastic fellow on our group of
world fellows Michael Calissa from
Rhonda and they went through all of this
after the genocide when they had like
only 12 judges left for the whole
country like all others were just killed
and they managed to rebuild it quite
fast you can record also on competitive
ground so on based on meritocracy from
from lawyers from all kind of floors you
can record new judges and the actually
is he'll be better judges in the the
current one the the the corrupt ones it
will be of course a challenge but it's a
challenge as real countries have
successfully overcome and he could do it
as well should we happen but thank you
very much thank you
well then thank you so much
[Music]